the streets of new york city turned blue
today as new york's finest turned out in
massive numbers to honor one of its
brothers
22 year old officer jason rivera who was
murdered in a harlem ambush just one
week ago
his partner 27 year old wilbert mora was
also shot and he died three days later
now rivera's funeral brought thousands
and thousands to st patrick's cathedral
where his young widow addressed the
mourners
and they all seem to feel a combination
of grief and anger
i couldn't believe you left me
seeing you in a hospital bed wrapped up
in sheets not hearing you when i was
talking to you broke me
today i'm still in this nightmare that i
wish i never had
full of rage and anger hurt
and sad
torn
although i gained thousands of blue
brothers and sisters
i'm the loneliest without you
oh my gosh it's just heartbreaking and
then toward the end of her remarks
came an absolutely stinging indictment
of the city's new far left district
attorney
the system continues to fail us
we are not safe anymore
not even the members of the service
i know you were tired of these laws
especially the ones from the new d.a
i hope he's watching you speak through
me right now
we promise
that your death won't be in vain
i love you to the end of time
we'll take the watch from here
[Applause]
joining me now is new york city
councilman joe borelli um joe it's good
to see you uh tonight but this was just
i mean there have been so many
heartbreaks uh in new york uh over the
past couple of years but
those words from officer rivera's widow
um
were just it was almost too much to take
it's it's difficult to even hear them
now uh hours later and not bring a tear
to anyone's eye but i hope america does
hear what you have to say because that
is a real new yorker that is what real
new yorkers believe and this powerful
woman gave us a window into her kitchen
table conversations with her husband a
new york city police department a person
of color a person who lived in manhattan
his whole life and they were scared
about those bail reform laws they were
scared about the laws and the
prosecution policies of our d.a alvin
bragg
and unfortunately
everyone but the albany legislature and
people stuck in the bubble of the state
capitol just have to realize that
these things need to be changed they
cannot go on in perpetuity
well the d.a bragg responded to those
words from rivera's widow in a statement
this afternoon joe saying that his
office is going to vigorously prosecute
cases of violence against police
officers
but
doesn't he realize that the permissive
policies
this is you know social justice leaning
policies that he's advocated help
contribute to this attitude if i can do
anything to a police officer and get
away with it
well this is why his statement is
garbage if this perp didn't shoot and
kill those police officers he probably
would have dropped some of the charges
against this guy if he was charged with
only a gun that's the type of prosecutor
alvin bragg is just ask alvin bragg he's
the one who's telling us he's not going
to charge people with gun crimes and
fully prosecute them according to the
law so it's just lip service from people
like him and unfortunately that has real
world consequences every single police
action whether it's a domestic violence
response like this or a traffic stop has
the potential of going south and if
police officers are not going to be
protected by the law if the prosecutors
are going to go after the people then we
have to reconsider whether it's even
worth the risk of sending cops in the
first place and it's unfortunate that
we're having this conversation in the
wake of the death of two of our our
finest people no it's open season on on
law-abiding new yorkers and
the men and women in blue but here's
what the most vocal critic of law
enforcement in the entire city is doing
she's grappling uh with all of this at
this moment the new york times notes
that councilwoman kristen richardson
jordan 35 has equated the policing
system with slavery and emphasized her
deep compassion for not only the fallen
officers but also for the man who the
police said killed them the greatest way
to honor the loss of life on all sides
loss of life due to gun violence she
said is to try to you know turn
all of this into more you know funding
for community programs and so forth
she's she's still for taking money away
from the officers and the law
enforcement itself
she's a complete disgrace
and kudos to some of my democratic
colleagues who've chimed in on her as
well i mean she's someone who represents
this neighborhood
officer rivera lived in this
neighborhood he's from northern
manhattan he's one of her constituents
just like everyone else and to mention
his name to mention the name of wilbert
mora in the same sentence almost
equivocating it with the man who killed
him is a new low
for some people that i thought couldn't
possibly go lower and yet here we are uh
people like this have no place in office
i'm happy to disagree with people all
the time and there's some decent people
i disagree with this person is not one
of them well joe thank you for being
here tonight